tyrion lannister the uh
dwarf character in game of thrones and
in the song of ice and fire
is i know for me and for many many many
others for just about everyone i think
it's probably everyone's favorite
character
in game in game of thrones and in the
song of ice and fire
and he has this really memorable moment
where he says i have a tender spot in my
heart for cripples
and bastards and broken things so many
many of your characters some of your
characters are these outsiders they're
either different or they're disabled in
some way like him and they seem to be
the only
characters that are capable of true
compassion
and yet they seem to suffer for it now
it's is this something you're conscious
of doing george as you're writing the
book
yeah definitely i mean yes i have a
large cast of viewpoint characters but
but uh for the most part they all have
something that makes them a bit of an
outcast you know tyrion is a
is a dwarf uh jon snow is a bastard
uh and danny who's you know beautiful
is a penniless exile
um who's being essentially sold off in
in marriage you know arya is is uh born
to a noble house
um but she's kind of this wild child who
she doesn't conform with her proper
gender roles brienne
of taurus even more doesn't conform to
her proper gender roles and because of
that she suffers a lot of scorn
and and rejection because she's not a
proper woman
in in the terms of her society um
sam tarly is is fat and bookish when a
lord is expected to be
warlike and strong and fierce and
good with a sword and sam as pawn would
rather read and dance and
listen to music and so he suffers a lot
of rejection and i could go on and on
uh but you know all of those people
you're talking have this honor code
as well they're the characters who have
an honor code within themselves that
they
almost need to hide right and
and that seems to make life even more
difficult for them in the world of
western even even a character like theon
greyjoy who's uh
not a character that a lot of people are
fond of um
because he's a weak character um i mean
he's
physically strong he's he's very skilled
with a bow he's uh you know a good
warrior
but he's he's a a character who's
suffering a lot of confusion about his
place in the world because
you know he's born of a noble family but
his father raised a rebellion
and his elder brothers were killed
during that rebellion and he was handed
over as a hostage at the end
theoretically a ward they called it but
still a hostage if his father creates
trouble
he used to be hung you know so that was
a frequent practice in the middle ages
when you didn't really trust one of your
underlords or an enemy who had bent the
knee you
took some of his children as wards or
hostages and um
so he called he he's a greyjoy by birth
and uh by some standards he's the heir
to
to the iron islands but he's been raised
in the household of eddard stark and
there's part of him who you know he has
these two fathers looming over him
neither one
who we can ever quite please and he's
desperate to find his place in the world
as
one or the other but from that confusion
a great
drama arises you know i mean
[Applause]
i think the best fiction the best
stories arise out of uh
conflict i've always taken as my my
mantra um
william faulkner's nobel prize
acceptance speech where he said
the only thing worth writing about is
the human heart and conflict with itself
and uh i think that's true of all
fiction whether it's science fiction or
fantasy
or literary fiction or mystery fiction
the human heart in conflict with itself
the characters who are having problems
um who are trying to decide the right
thing to do who are trying to make some
sense of their life who are
trying to find their place in the world
or or
any of these issues these are what make
characters real these are the things
that real people do and
and um that's the characters i love to
read about
those are the characters i love to write
about i mentioned earlier that
so far the song of ice and fire isn't
following the hero's journey it doesn't
seem to be anyway
i wonder are you consciously trying to
discard that that old trope
or do you feel still obliged to write
within that thing the hero is going to
go out to the world they mean challenges
giving it much thought one way or the
other um really i mean this is
this is kind of a known template in
hollywood yeah and a screenwriter you
would have been hit over the head with
it many times i would have thought
yeah but it doesn't interest me you know
i i read a lot of books i get books sent
to me all the time for blurbing and of
course i've been a voracious reader
since i was a small child
and one of the things
that i learned when i was still a small
child than a high school kid was that
there would be certain patterns
in in
storytelling that were very predictable
and i began to predict them and i very
quickly
even as a teenager i lost interest in
the predictable stories the stories that
went exactly
where i wanted to uh want it to go
you know we were we were talking uh a
little before the show about uh our
shared
past in comic books yeah uh you know i
my first
first things i never published were
letters in in the comic books of the
marvel comic books of the early 1960s
the avengers and
and uh fantastic four and spider-man and
so forth
um i was very impressed with those and
i was born in 1948 so i started reading
comics in the 50s just around the time
that the silver age began the
crime comics and horror comics were
going out superheroes were coming back
after
like a decade's absence and at first
they came back with dc
with uh julia schwartz editing and
characters like
the flash and green lantern and uh the
justice league were brought back in new
incarnations
and i loved these comics but they were
very predictable it was you know the
flash was a good guy green lantern was a
good guy
uh the adam was a good guy hawkman was a
good guy they were all good guys and
every issue they fought a bad guy
and the bad guys weren't terribly bad in
the 50s they were mostly guys trying to
rob banks
but they were just uh you know they were
they were bad guys they were criminals
and
the the hero would catch them by the end
of the book and then
next issue there would be another bad
guy who was trying to take over the
world or trying to rob a bank or
trying to get revenge and the hero would
stop him and then
marvel came along and with stan lee
writing and
that was you know the first times i was
writing letters and getting them
published
and it was so revolutionary to me it's
it's hard to
looking back for people who weren't
there to conceive of how shocking these
comics were because
stanley threw out the rules i mean with
the fantastic four
the character of the thing he was a
monster he
he looked like the early marvel monster
comics he was like made of orange rocks
and he had a
ferocious temper and he he didn't want
to be the thing
he was like this tragic hero and he
would go into rages and he would
fight with uh mr fantastic
yeah in the early issues he had a thing
for sue storm too and he and reid
richards were both
interested in the same group that never
happened at dc you know superman had
lois lane you know you never saw batman
hitting on lois lane
batman had his own his own girlfriend
you know behind the very
flash had his own girlfriend you know
people didn't
everything was was very much in order in
dc
and over in in marvel it was it was just
chaos characters who didn't like each
other characters who didn't want to be
heroes
and then like one of the early letters i
i had printed was uh the
an issue of the avengers where a
character called wonder man was
introduced
and he was this great new hero wonder
man and he he joined the avengers
but he seemed to be a good guy but he
was actually a bad guy
who had been sent to undermine the
avengers but at the end
he turned out to be a good guy because
he couldn't go through it being a bad
guy and he died in the same issue
this great new hero died in the same
issue as he was introduced
it had tremendous impact on me it was it
was like stanley was saying
no one is safe anything can happen in
these books
you know all of these things are off the
off the table now because it was comics
they brought him back you know
a couple years later but uh still the
fact that he died
it was a it was a tragic story here and
the the thing
coming to that as a 13 and 14 year old i
was tremendously impressed with that
and i've always remained impressed with
uh with stories where you don't know
what was going to happen
i mean um no one is safe anything can
happen
yes and tolkien you know in some ways
led the way for that i mean the the
fellowship of rings set out
and you know the death of boromir had
enormous impact on me and then the
seeming death of gandalf
uh you know that incredible moment in
in a fellowship of the ring where where
the balrog drags gandalf down into the
abyss and you think he's dead do you
think he's dead for
you know a good part of the rest of that
book and the first part of the next book
um if it been me i probably would have
let him stay dead
uh because the impact of losing gandalf
gandalf was the leader he was the one
who knew what was going to happen he was
the
the father figure the wise guy he he
always
could tell you what to do and what was
the meaning of this and now
it was like the children are in charge
the the father's
dead father's dead yeah what are you
gonna do now now you have to save the
world oh god what a feeling that was
and you know that set me up perfectly
for then the end of uh
uh the second book the two towers when
it seems as though frodo is dead frodo's
been stung by shelab
and sam takes the ring and he leaves
frodo and i was this
reeling and saying my god they've killed
i thought frodo was a hero they've
killed
frodo how could he do this you know and
i really didn't know what was going to
happen at the end of that book
and that's the feelings that i had
reading those things are the feelings
that i try to
replicate for for my readers